well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Christina the shits
to your house big words yeah so we're
him I want to use those big words at
that station very casually to like yell
ways this is have you recognize Steve
Lobel here now he was on an episode of
Millionaire Matchmaker was he talking
like this yeah even that show yeah
memmer and she was like okay what is
your deal as a manager um so he's worked
with a lot of big hip-hop acts he's been
around for you know probably 30 years
and so he picks up the affectations of
the rappers and while he's like in New
York you know dude from just a black guy
New York yeah yeah this is he just
another black guy with the wrong fucking
skin tone and this and Pun was just
heightening and pum would always want to
use my cell phone and I'm like I got a
call radio I got a call retail and we
have like $60 relatively games like $60
deep with two fat niggas per diem yeah
and and wait who's into he was
interviewing doesn't sound like a black
guy right well yeah well they get into
it actually you know and the the the big
words big words are actually big this
weekend because Larry Wilmore the host
of the the nightly show on Comedy
Central
he did the White House Correspondents
Dinner you know set where you go up and
you basically light the you know the
journal is sometimes the administration
on fire he crushed it I mean he was just
he was no-holds-barred just lighting it
and that room was not into it they do
not like his one time I did a set at the
journalism awards here in Los Angeles
and I have never eaten shit harder I
mean I this was like two or three years
ago so I've been doing stand-up for a
minute yeah and events like that are
very difficult I mean they drop the
dessert just as I was going on but I
would have eaten shit otherwise there
are real nerds at this dinner you know
yeah and that swing is that that's a
roomful of like real world elites yeah
not just that yes right but that's
usually had their senators there's right
now it's like hosting the Oscars it's
just like super elite people who take
themselves too seriously and when you
have someone like Wilmore who's digging
into you really really lighting people
up they go this isn't poor
tastes because it they don't feel like
it's nice you know and they get their
feelings hurt but but he ended I mean
let me see if I could pull this up tie
this all together
he ended seafood Thank You mr. president
when I met Larry Wilmore earlier this
month he told me it's his dream come
true to follow the president at the
White House for a spot president that
doesn't make sense
Barry and now to live in your time mr.
pres this is how he ended this on a
black man can lead the entire free world
hello Donna
I like on my pan to the people that are
black yeah they always do like Oh words
alone do me no justice
um so mr. president I'm going to keep it
a hundred yo Barry
you did it my nigga you like that Obama
laughter obviously there was backlash
even from a lot of people a lot of black
people oh right
I felt it was very disrespectful to say
that to the president of United Shore
anyways I didn't I mean I'm white but I
didn't know but I cuz I thought it was
it was done with a lot of affection I
thought he wasn't yeah I mean I realize
you're saying it to the president but
right but but I was with everything in
comedy I think the intent is really what
kid yeah it's a black man saying it to
another black man and he wasn't saying
it the way that other guy I like the way
so let's go back to yeah that's a
difference yeah it's totally different
um Steve Lobel if I'm saying oh I
thought that guy was the guy that the
bodyguard from what know we found a kid
man in India like money
white guy Steve Wilkos uh Steve Wilkos
looks a little bit cameras he'll uh here
we go a lot of people stressed look at
the president ain't sweating the n-bomb
he's then who cares when it only matters
to I think him the president took it
though that way that this is coming from
a place of affection oh and a comedian
too he didn't hire the median but
whatever people have the right to be
whatever memory but this is this is
different this is a little different
here so you still he's doing the
interview here and he just kind of keeps
going then we found the kid man that
made erect with 50 I feel like money
buzzing buzzing that's been in LA
getting niggas jewelry back hold the
niggas down discovering people
consulting people helping people knows
real talk you see so they laugh they're
like okay okay
I don't know how I'd feel to hearing him
say that stuff yeah we gotta be like
what wait can we pause uh yeah he keeps
rolling today it's no big deal
I just droppin bombs like oh my god yeah
you got yeah he's really get into it
drop him you lend a niggah a pencil
right so he he continues I think they
must have obviously at some point asked
him like what is up with you doing this
you know um why are you so you have to
be part of the community right well I
think the thing is that he considers him
but it's a good point I think he does
consider himself part of that community
mm-hm
I don't think he thinks that he's not
but I don't think you're you're allowed
really and until you you meet a certain
criterion which is being black well that
would be the thought of a lot of people
but not this guy they just know you as
like little baby right yeah if you in
New York person like there's the problem
I live in LA right and I meet girls and
you're like why do you act like Dan why
do you talk like Dan and dressed like
that like you must have never been in
New York down because the white boys are
just like me and he probably got tats
and and he fight go to right cuz on all
that I thought well I remember I told
you that I don't know what I mean he's
just he's saying like good Rikers yeah
yeah break this fucking guy I love him
why people try to sweat the plight say
my black people have it like no dude no
bro trust me you're still not and he
you're causing yourself problems at this
point you know also implying that white
people from New York are like black
people they go to jail a lot that is
basically that's what he just said fight
fight mantle Rikers Island
that's um and then that guy this is it
must be when he like defended his use of
it right so here he goes I walk at your
room be your white people Russell
Russell Simmons there was something
they're gonna like Russell these he's
white hey yo just so you can't explain
that so nigga it doesn't mean a black
person to me
a nigga's a slave there's Mexican slaves
Jewish slaves
black slaves white slaves I grew up
nigga nigga nigga that's my nigga in LA
once a blood dude said to me yo you said
that word and I was around sugar at the
time and I was in the studio without
laws and stuff and it was
a lot of guns it was a lot of craziness
because a lot of executives who are
white they don't want to be around the
Hennessy the guns and the dogs they
don't be on the tall buses they just
want to come around to certain things
and take the credit after the fact and
he's like you need to go to bank many
only 15,000 saying nigga I send my nigga
you're gonna kill me right now
ain't no one extorting me white niggers
so yeah
do you think there's a reason that the
white executives don't come around when
there's guns and Hennessy involved like
he obviously wants to be there for that
yeah that's right Lilly maybes not a
white thing name is just a thing yes the
person wants to stay alive doesn't hang
out with Suge and those people no sugars
the people is a death sentence you don't
want to die hang out with Suge Knight
even in prison I'll be like don't hang
out yeah we're not gonna be Bros Lee
I've seen a lot of white there's in my
time this guy but I love what he's
trying to convince them like I can use
the word because because Russell Simmons
said it to me once yeah and I want to be
yeah right and then all of you what yeah
you know Oh white yeah uh-huh a big
words yeah yeah very big right I just
kills me when like you're born a white
guy which is like top of the food chain
in America big words
yeah motherfucker like you're at the top
what are you doing yeah you have it
pretty dumb prick just be a white guy
enjoy it's not feeling guilty and weird
about it you won the cosmic lottery
asshole yeah you know the easiest
position you're making life hard for you
then you know say I used to come it I
like that a that when he said that this
zoom again because he he goes he says
he's hanging out in that studio and some
blood saw some gangbanger go to the bank
and get me $15,000 for saying that word
right and then in his version of the
story he says it again to that guy do
you understand yes like so yeah he an
his his version of a dude who just a
gang member who was just like go to the
bank and get me money is that he told
that guy you're gonna have to extort me
right but I gotta use the word but I'm
gonna say it on the tour buses they just
want to come around this only 15,000
saying nigga
so my nigga you gonna kill right my yeah
so the guy just said hate me you can't
say that go give me money and that I'm
gonna respond as I'm saying nigga I said
my nigga you gonna kill me right now
ain't no one extorting me you didn't
really not you didn't Steve Wilkos did
not say Steve Wilkos was with Jerry
Springer everyday yeah he would never he
was too busy gardening son what a psycho
ridiculous shit oh my god but y'all
Donny I'll finish y'all finish y'all
done